[Applause]
this whole thing yeah you get that when
you walk down the street New York hey
Lou Hey look are you doing man
yes great work it's New York City people
are really nice though this is the whole
thing the whole thing is I believe
unprecedented in movies a 20 year old
movie re-released it's number one and
the box off George had me to lunch and
he told George Lucas yes he told me his
idea and brilliant savvy businessman
that I am I said George that's a
terrible idea
everyone seen these movies a million
times of course when I told my kids they
were ecstatic and I said haven't you
guys seen this enough on videotape they
want to see it large they want to see it
loud and I'd forgotten but that's not
true of like every movie if they'd be
released or Herbie the lovebug or
something a good example you know up the
first Pauly Shore movie you know on the
big screen you know with restored
footage you're not duty with enhanced
footage you couldn't see that you
wouldn't see lines around the block I'd
be there and he'd be there but probably
falling into a toilet I didn't see that
in the original version well you know I
haven't seen him since they first came
out I have to ask my son is that new is
that new is that new I don't know really
well it's hard to tell you know and I
was just kind of kidding around and I
said on one radio show you know gee the
princess lay a nude ice dancing sequence
was worth it you know the price of
admission alone Fox get you know called
me right away and said you know people
took that seriously so cut it out right
so you're pretty much a corporate tool
then you do any much a corporate tool
you know ooh look out for Fox well I'm
not afraid of them huh
[Applause]
unless they're watching of course oh god
I've ruined my food you know you
mentioned doing the radio show you've
done quite a bit of promotion I know
have done yeah when people show up on
this show they've really doing a lot of
promotion and I'm just kidding a little
self-deprecating humor but you're doing
a lot of promotion I understand you've
taken some of your promotion for this
movie to a new level you know they found
a kind of an interesting new venue for
for Star Wars publicity in fact I think
we have a clip clip yeah I think we do
don't we all right let's take a look at
this
[Music]
Oh - Princess Leia fans there's a funny
story got Kari you know she was really
self-conscious about her hair you you
were very kind to go over and shoot that
for us it had actual Peep Show yes and
it was the highlights oh that's a good
one - yeah I've always been looking for
an excuse to go in there you know so it
was fun did you have a good time there I
heard you really sort of loosened up
well you I wanted to be able to say that
I really experienced the full experience
so I don't know I waited till your
cameras were gone but you know I I had
my wife she would a shot of me
bottomless so I could say that I was
actually nude in one of those viewing
booths it was like I see the hot wait a
minute so the Fox corporation isn't
gonna be upset now well I thought I was
one of those you know one of those
late-night setups where you know the
National Enquirer is gonna jump out and
get me get a picture of you doing yeah
you bet you never know with you guys say
if you took off your pants
[Laughter]
yeah all right now you I'm told I didn't
know this was the case because you don't
you didn't get to use this skill in in
the actual Star Wars trilogy but I
understand that you're quite an
impressionist is that the case well it's
not so much that I'm an impressionist
but when you tell stories you sort of
affect whatever person that you're doing
to try and give the flavor for for what
you're talking about I remember I was
complaining to Harrison that my hair
didn't match from the last scene and it
was bad for continuity in Harrison's
comment was it could if the audience is
looking at your hair we're all in big
[Laughter]
new try working with Yoda for three
months and the it's a puppet is a puppet
but guy is like insane
we're just like that I'd ask him out for
a drink and he'd never leave rudia we
drove Frank Oz crazy though because not
just me but the entire crew we'd break
for lunch and they would everybody would
be talking like hungry are you to lunch
you are going a cheese
[Applause]